thank you very much appreciate you being
here like to take a few moments to
describe what we're doing on numerous
fronts but we're gonna take a major step
in our historic regulatory reduction
campaign today we begin a bold new
initiative to bring down the cost of
housing for American families so
important in a few moments I'll sign an
executive order launching the White
House Council on eliminating regulatory
barriers to affordable housing I'm
grateful to be joined by the chair of
this new council secretary ben Carson
we're also pleased to have with us
Senators tim scott and martha mcsalley
and here with us are Clyde from Congress
Clyde Holland Greg Google d-roc Bonnie
Roberts Burke pastor Daryl Scott and
you're not a congressman yet pastor but
you could give you honor too I can tell
you like to run for Congress because you
win thank you for being a pastor Kareem
Lanier all the people who really care so
much about affordable housing what it
means and how important it is for our
country over regulation of housing and
the housing market is a primary cause of
the rising housing costs across our
country nationwide it's estimated that
the regulations account for more than
25% of the cost of a new home think of
it so regulation and unnecessary
regulation is 25% the cost of a new home
as a result the supply of affordable
housing cannot keep up with demand today
over 37 million American households have
to spend more than 30 percent of their
income on housing so what I'd like to do
is ask Ben Carson who's really devoted a
lot of his time and effort to this
tremendous over regulation problem I'd
like to have Ben Carson secretary just
saying a few words Ben well thank you
mr. president and thank you for your
continued commitment
to the people of America today I'm
privileged to be here for the creation
of the White House Council on
eliminating barriers to affordable
housing which I have the great honor to
chair the console which consists of
members across eight federal agencies
will lead federal efforts to engage with
state local and tribal leaders across
the country to remove the obstacles that
impede the production of more affordable
homes namely the enormous price tag of
burdensome government regulations
president has given us a mission to
break down barriers and to clear the
path for the millions of Americans to
pursue their American dream it's a
mission we proudly and enthusiastically
accept as the president just said more
than 25% of the cost of a new home is
the direct result of federal state and
local regulations and sometimes the
price tag is much higher than that
president Trump's decades of experience
as a world renowned builder and
developer gives this administration's
leadership a unique set of insights when
confronting the challenges of developing
more housing
today's announcement recognizes the need
for federal policies to serve Americans
of all income levels including
working-class Americans like teachers
and nurses and auto mechanics
construction workers policemen firemen
whose struggles are sometimes forgotten
and I would also like to thank President
Trump and the leadership of this
administration many of whom are here
today for once again fulfilling that
great promise that The Forgotten men and
women of America will be forgotten no
longer I look forward to working
alongside my fellow council members in
the months ahead as we use these efforts
to continue to build the pillars of
prosperity that support all the men and
women of this country in their quest for
that portion of the American dream that
include
at home the home is the foundation of
the community which is the foundation of
the nation and we can do this if we all
work together Thank You mr. president
thank you for this executive order
there's no doubt that our regulatory
reset that is responsible will help more
Americans or creditworthy achieve their
goal their aspiration of having a part a
share and this nation the American a
dream so often is seen through the prism
of home ownership this executive order
will accelerate the path of Responsible
home ownership and is proof positive
that you're conscientious compassionate
conservative leadership it's undeniably
focused on the most vulnerable folks of
our economic team thank you so much for
this executive order in the first 90
days as a senator in Arizona I visited
all 15 counties we're a very diverse
state and our economy is growing but a
top theme is affordable housing and
there are many barriers to that and so
this group coming together to cut across
those barriers federal state and local
to provide more opportunities at lower
cost so everybody can meet their full
potential is really important for my
constituents and so I'm grateful for
this initiative thank you great job
Pastor Scott during the 2016 campaign
you stated that you would implement
national policy to revitalize the urban
communities of this great country and
well the communities are in that role
and I think this is just a part there's
dovetails on the opportunity zones and
the things that are being done in those
designated areas and this makes it makes
the revitalization process that much
more obtainable so we thank you for it
the words because Tim Scott had so much
to do with that and it's far beyond our
expectation that's a little different
than what we're talking about today but
when you bring up that term it's
beautiful term Tim Scott came to see me
a little while ago toward the beginning
but not that long ago sir and and Tim I
don't mind if you say just a couple of
things about what's happened because the
opportunity zones have just taken off in
this country yes sir mr. president
because of your leadership frankly we
have seen incredible growth in the
opportunity zones here's just a couple
of examples I think it's important for
us to remember that an opportunity zones
the average person is living in a place
where the poverty rate is at 31%
nationally our poverty rates at 12 and
1/2 percent because of your legislation
that you signed sir we've seen an 8
percent increase in wages within the
zones we've seen a 20% increase in
property values in the zones that's
really important for two reasons number
one over 50% of the folks in the zones
own their property so that means that
we're seeing net worth increase because
of the opportunities of legislation so
that's really important number two the
fact the matter is when you put more
pressure on those zones you attract more
resources in it and from the Treasuries
of the perspective we could see upwards
of more than 50 billion dollars
descending upon these zones creating
opportunities and workforce housing that
we're talking about today and that is a
important part of the equation and that
is brought to us by your leadership and
your willingness to have a conversation
about moving people and distressed
communities forward thank you for saying
yes Holland with respect to the National
Housing Council and up for Growth two
areas we've been struggling to produce
apartments and the most affordable
housing in America we can't thank you
enough mr. president for this help thank
you
appreciated yes put this the president
thank you for this and I would like to
thank you as well about the Carson for
your leadership as well coming from the
inner city coming from urban America
living within the confines of what it
takes on a day-to-day we don't care
about the cost in the regular we need
the housing and so it's good that we
have these barriers removed so that we
can actually get access to these things
when you're a kid living in urban
America you don't care who your
president is who your governor is who
your mare is you care about the things
that are practical to you and the things
that really are practical is where am I
going to lay my head at tonight and what
am I gonna eat when I get there and
these things help more people in urban
America get access to housing that is so
needed and so we thank you tremendously
thank you National Association of
Realtors and as a Realtor that I thank
you very very much the American Dream is
homeownership we have the lowest
percentage of homeownership that we've
had in many many years and I think this
is going to go a long way to increase
that thank you very much Greg you gal D
on behalf of the home builders mr.
president we are strongly behind this
effort the regulatory framework
throughout the country needs to be
focused on it'll help us with workforce
development as well and I think that
this is tremendous and we thank you for
this thank you very much I appreciate it
I just want to add you know the average
net worth of a renter it's $5,000 the
average net work of a homeowner is
$200,000 that's a 40 fold difference and
we talked so much about the income gap
the wealth gap in this country a lot of
it has to do with home ownership and
that's why this is so important but it
has to be done the right way it wasn't
done the right way you know a decade or
more
and it led to a crisis so we have to
learn from those situations do it the
right way and it's really about
recognizing that our people are a most
important resource and we need to
develop it and the best place to develop
those resources is a solid home justice
reform efforts with the lowest
unemployment because of your tax cuts
and regulatory reform effort with your
fight for school choice so children have
a real opportunity for an education to
evanka and your workforce the pledge to
the American worker all of that combined
lifts all boats but it lifts those at
the bottom of the socio-economic ladder
the most and that's because of your
leadership so we're just so grateful to
you thank you thank you for bringing up
criminal justice reform we got it passed
nobody else could have gotten it passed
and we're very proud of that a lot of
people work very hard on that and I see
it's a big part of the debates and now
they're all saying it got passed and it
got passed by a Republican named Trump
and the Democrats don't know quite how
to handle that one but we did criminal
justice reform very comprehensive also
and there are a lot of people and the
incredible thing about it was we had
conservatives very very conservative and
we had very very liberal people
supporting it we had everybody we had a
great bipartisan group and we had some
people opposed to a - but we had for the
most part tremendous support so thank
you very much Larry Cutler do you want
to just give a moment about how well our
economy is doing because it looks like
June could be one of the best months in
the history of the stock market for June
for that month most extraordinary and
it's a terrific sign about the future
economy really good sign
we had our correction in the spring now
we've gotten it back then
and numbers coming out deduction way up
in Maine consumer spending retail sales
way up and a we're gonna have a better
q2 than people initially thought I think
we're on track for a 3% economic growth
or better and reminder Brooking love tax
rates deregulation opening up energy
trade reform initiatives like this from
secretary bent and others this is what
it takes we're opening doors well well
every nook and cranny of this economy is
coming alive if we stay on track with
your policies gonna be great news for
everyone in the world if you look at
Europe they're having difficulty you
look at China in various parts of the
world Asia other places we're beating
everybody and we're gonna keep it that
way so I'm gonna sign this and Bend
congratulations we've been working on
this for a long time
[Applause]
personally concerned are you personally
concerned about the conditions at these
border facilities and they're much
better than they were on the President
Obama by far and we're trying to get the
Democrats to agree to really give us
some humanitarian aid humanitarian money
and that is a very fair question and I
appreciate that question but I'm very
concerned it's a much better shape than
it ever was a lot of these young
children come from places that you don't
even want to know about the way they've
lived the way they've been the way that
the poverty that they grew up in but
with that if we can get this bill signed
we'll be able to do it we have you know
the Democrats don't want to sign
anything and now I think they're going
to probably sign this from what I
understand it's I call it you mana
terian aid this isn't even about border
at the same time you see the numbers of
way way down Mexico has been really
helping us a lot they're very strong
immigration laws they are moving 15,000
people or 16,000 people to our southern
border and they move 16,000 troops to
their southern border which is pretty
incredible and a lot of signs are coming
out where the cartels and all of the bad
folks the Coyotes as they call them and
all of the bad people that are bringing
young children and taking advantage
horribly it's a form of slavery it's
horrible what they're doing to young
children you understand you've reported
on it a lot of that is stopping now
because of what we're doing and because
of what's happening on the border so I
just want to thank Mexico they've really
done a great job we appreciate what
they're doing and hopefully they can
keep it up
because it's very important I am very
very Mexico is very very powerful
immigration laws they can do things our
laws are so bad what we would like to do
and I'll do it right now officially is
ask the Democrats to give us help on
Asylum help on all of the loopholes the
horrible loopholes that can signed in
over a period of years that don't allow
us to do what we should be able to do we
need the votes of Democrats and I think
very importantly you know because our
economy you heard Larry Kudlow
because our economy is so strong could
be the strongest in the history of our
country people want to flow up to the
United States but you just can't do it
that way you have to do it legally but
there you have these massive numbers of
people trying to get into the United
States because of the economy because
we've done so good but that's one of the
problems with doing well everybody wants
to come in ten years ago five years ago
four years ago they didn't want to come
in today they want to come in but we
can't let that happen so we're doing
very merciful and and as far as the wall
is concerned the wall is heavily under
construction the Army Corps of Engineers
is doing a great job we're doing a lot
of wall right now and we expect to have
400 miles built by the end of next year
that's a lot of rebuilding them in the
right places we're building were picking
areas where we need it the most and it's
having a tremendous effect order
protection had John Sanders to resign do
you know why he's leaving his home no I
know who's gonna be a change there I've
made changes very good changes we have
were moving some people around in two
different locations the game has changed
a lot because of what Mexico is doing
we're able to do things that we wouldn't
have been able to do before the problem
with our Border Patrol who are
phenomenal people but they're not
allowed because the laws is so bad with
catch-and-release and all of the
different things including chain
migration the Visa Lottery the laws are
so bad and the asylum rules and laws are
so bad that our Border Patrol people who
are so incredible aren't allowed to do
their jobs
so because Mexico is now for the first
time in 50 years helping us and we
really appreciate it
we're able to make certain changes that
we wouldn't have been able to make
before Steve together back and forth
with the leader of Iran this morning by
a tweet what message did you want to
send to him with your tweezers message
you know I'll tell you what the message
is when they're ready to have to let us
know when they're ready they'll let us
know very simple
ready to do whatever doesn't make any
difference whatever they want to do I'm
ready okay without the Israelis or
Palestinian official attending so what's
your strategy going forward when there's
no buy-in from we have to get economic
support because the Palestinians don't
have money and we have to help the
Palestinians with some money because
they don't have it and one of the groups
that you get are some of those countries
in the Middle East that do have money so
they're going to play a role in the
peace plan and we'll see what happens we
had a little bit of a setback when the
election from in Israel as you know is I
guess the result is somewhat mixed
because now they're going to do it again
that's another do-over unfortunately and
but we'll see what happens I mean we'll
see what happens with that election but
it's an early process but we expect
other people to help out because again
there's no money and some people don't
have money and if they don't have money
it's going to be very hard we want
people to be able to live and live well
I don't think I've ever spoken to
actually no we have some very good
people running it and you know I don't
know anything about it I hear he's a
very good man I hear is a good person I
don't know him I don't think I ever
spoke so Stephanie has been with me from
the beginning as most of you know and
then over the last couple years she's
worked for the first lady done a
fantastic job the first lady loves her
I think she's been you know just
incredible very talented and I hear so
many people who do you like a lot of
people wanted to jump you know a lot of
people wanted to do it and I'd ask
people who do you like and so many
people said Stephanie and she's here she
knows everybody she actually gets along
with the media very well as you know a
lot of the folks in the media liked her
very much and I think she's gonna be
fantastic I think she's gonna do a great
job so I offered her the job this
morning and she accepted and the first
lady is very happy for her
it's a big job it's a very big job
but we think stephanie's going to do a
fantastic job and Hogan's going to be
with her Hogan was one of the people
that recommended his Hogan he
recommended her very strongly I said
Hogan who do you think he said Stephanie
worship so does break up how do you do
you have an exit strategy for Iran if
war does break out you're not gonna need
an exit strategy I don't need things and
strategies back and forth he wrote me a
beautiful letter on birthday as my
birthday as you know last week he wrote
me a beautiful letter I thought it was
very nice and just too friendly letters
we get along very well
maybe there was but we you know at some
point we'll do that getting along very
well he's not doing nuclear testing when
I took over as you know when I became
president they were testing the previous
to that they were testing so much that
we're doing ballistic tests and nuclear
tests and we didn't have our prisoners
back we had a whole lot of things that
were going wrong now we have our
hostages back or prisoners back they
came back we've had as you know the the
remains of the heroes are great heroes
for many years ago that's coming back
and coming back as they find them and as
they find the sites and the graves
they're sending them back the
relationship is a far different
relationship than it was during the
Obama years where are you gonna end up
with a war you gonna end up with a war
in North Korea that I can tell you I'll
tell that to Phil Scott maybe you ever
heard of that Ken whatever you
understand okay what you could end up in
a war in North Korea and if it kept
going the way it was going if you had
that group continuing onward as far as
Iran is concerned the deal was a
horrible deal it was no good it was no
good it ended in a very short period of
time we're dealing about countries it
ended in a very short period of time
they would have had a clear path to a
nuclear weapon we're not going to allow
that to happen can't do it and I'm all
for Iran I have so many people Iranian
friends I come from New York I have
tremendous numbers of
Rainie and friends and great people
there from Iran they're wonderful people
it's too bad this is happening they're
living badly right now
their country is not doing well
economically at all that can be changed
very quickly very easily but they have
to get rid of the hostility from the
leadership the leadership I hope they
stay I hope they do a great job but they
should talk to us decently we're we're
all for them we wanted to be done
properly but the deal that was done by
President Obama 150 billion for nothing
he used the money for terror they gave
the money out to terrorists if you
remember John Kerry they asked him that
question do you know that money's going
to be used to tear he said yes
essentially he said at least some of its
going to be using I mean he knew about
it he actually said that some of the
money may be used for terror what kind
of a deal is that then they gave him 1.8
billion in cash cash plane loads of cash
what kind of a deal is that and the
biggest problem is they had bad testing
you weren't able to see many of the
sights you saw that Tim you couldn't go
into the most important sites to test to
see they were probably making this stuff
for a long time but with a hundred and
fifty billion dollars going to them they
were doing very well and 1.8 billion in
cash and you had no real right of
testing you couldn't test properly and
most importantly the agreement ends in a
very short period of time so they had a
path to nuclear weapons
we cannot allow Iran to have a path to
nuclear weapons and by the way we have
tremendous support tremendous support
and people who are very happy with what
I did the other day by not doing
something okay but we had tremendous and
we have tremendous support nobody wants
to see Iran have nuclear weapons thank
you very much everybody
do you think they understood the message
you were sending them last week you
decided not to strike I hope they
understood the message I decided not to
strike they shut down unmanned as you
know an unmanned drone I think everybody
does I think you do too
goodbye
[Music]